who gave you the notorious nickname the
baddest [ __ ] hey everybody welcome to
another episode of hot box and I'm Evan
Britain and I'm Mike Tyson like we got a
great guest this is awesome bring the
strong women in the in the hot box I
agree on to the center let's get this
poppet well we've that we've got Trina
welcome thank you thank you for having
me absolutely going on Trina what you
don't I'm I just dropped my new album
which is called the one yeah right yeah
how'd you guess yes I have on two chains
on the album a half lies little boo see
I have Nicki Minaj on the album I have
little Wayne on the album k.michelle
Kelly Price how's it going how's it
going if the album hit they get paid or
something how that goes well yeah they
do for your people so we're gonna put
some yeah sometimes sometimes it depends
on how to relationship you have with the
artist some artists they'll do it and
it's you could just do it I'm gonna do
this feature for you someone to get a
fee for it summer do a trade-off you're
doing for me I do I back for you and you
know that's just kind of how it works it
depends on the relationship yeah all
right cool so it's good to have good
relationships you know yeah absolutely
yeah absolutely
Rico love he's also my album actually he
kind of co-produced the album if he nice
huh he own the show with you Ricola what
no he's not on the show he assures on
the love of hip-hop Miami oh okay he
comes on every now and then like for
advice or god I sort of a studio stuff
like that all right cool I'll look it
into I mean I'm interested in what that
is like on the show I love hip-hop
yeah well let's take it back Donnie
would it be fair
say that you came in to rap by chance
uh yeah yeah yeah tell us about that how
did you come into music
it happened kinda because I was friends
with Rick and he just had made that he
had put on an album and you know he was
a we offer Miami so I was supporting him
already and then he wanted the label on
him to another record featuring a female
and it wasn't really for me to be
rapping on the record I came on the
record to kind of just like you know
like talk trash and like intro and sell
out and you know girl vs. guy but when I
got in the studio it went left and he
wanted me to like go in the studio and
do verses for the record like listen to
what he said and then say to say
something better like for the girls
could like it's a chant now we're at war
with the girl with the guy so that's how
it kind of happened so it was like I was
it was spontaneous but it was hilarious
I was nervous I was scared because I
thought I was know like a little intro
so that was cool but when I went into
this whole different way I totally I was
nervous but was it something that did it
come natural to you yeah you know what
it did because I feel like he just knew
I was feisty kinda I had this feistiness
so when I got in there I was I was doing
that same method like I was just talking
I was talking trash I was saying you
know saying whatever I wanted to say but
then when he was like like saying it
saying it say it in bars so it was kind
of like I was breaking it down now to
make it make sense now to make it rhyme
now to make it like really converted to
what he was saying so then that's how
for me I mean was like I just got in
there did it it didn't seem like I was
you know had a hard time I just I was
like this is what come to my mind I put
this down together I have my girls
hyping me up he loved it and the song
became a hit that's awesome
cuz you just came with the energy I came
with the energy the top the swag yeah
you just need a little coaching put it
all together yeah that's dope and it's
interesting to hear you talk about you
you were you were kind of scared or
nervous and had a lot of anxiety yes cuz
Mike and I talked about that all the
time in sports I'm scared to death no
way get that really if I wasn't
disciplined I will leave my gentleman
would never
come back really yeah oh wow and I'd be
thinking I'm about to get on a do a show
and I'm scared you would never be able
to tell you're scared
that's a whole lot of a lot of
preparation a lot of experience I don't
care how experienced your how great your
you get those feelings yeah when you
stop having those feelings it's over I
tell people that all the time they asked
me what drives you what keeps you going
I say the moment I stop having that
feeling then that's when I know it's
over so once you have that feeling
oh wow that's interesting I learned
something yeah absolutely butterflies
yeah like energy building yourself
I do it every time before the show yeah
yeah yeah I mean that's what that's like
the fuel yeah that's amazing
you were of the generation of female
rappers you really opened the door for a
lot of female rappers to come in and I
mean around that time or a little bit
before you was Lauryn Hill and Lil Kim
and how did what was your relationship
like with them as you were coming into
it I mean well when I came into the game
it was like a handful of women there was
Missy Elliott there was Kim there was a
Fred Fox it was like it was a whole
bunch of your own women and so it was a
different kind it wasn't very embracing
you know everybody you know had their
own space but still sit when everybody
got together it was like you it was
immunity you know everybody kind of
clicked we used to hang out to different
events you know different shows or
whatever so it was it was a good way for
me to come in especially to these women
that I already liked I saw on TV I was
like yes I love them in now you're in
front of them you meet them and then
they're like super dope in person she's
a nice lady I never like nobody I want
anybody but power-down touching me
egomaniac what is your job is different
like you have to have this tough
exterior like game face right I don't
know what it was that was you oh is that
one day yeah what the [ __ ] are you
looking at
this podcast that happened 20 years ago
no no the [ __ ] you looking at age
humbles you so 20 years ago this
definitely wouldn't the pot I'll be
hitting on you talking [ __ ] okay it's
not really this phase right now right
yeah absolutely yes you know getting to
the bottom of what Pete makes people
tick yeah what makes you to success
power um I think all of it yeah honestly
power definitely first when you first
had the first hit records power boom you
wanted to target you want to keep
feeling that what are they feeling
they're saying fire that same energy I
was I undefeated why nobody can tell me
nothing it was just the fire that was
fueling yeah the power just to feel
powerful and just do you think that come
from that feeling um hmm I don't know I
think I think it's I don't know probably
just like a rage of passion or something
I don't know something I don't know for
me I know when it's in a moment when I'm
gonna I made was something I've
conquered something that become that big
or feel that great to me I'm like half
of me is thinking like wow I can't
believe I did that
or damn yeah I just did that like you
know it's just I get like two different
type of feelings I understand that but
the power light you know understand yeah
the power overwhelms you yeah sometimes
it does to me you know sometimes I'm
funny with tools sometimes I don't have
a good opinion about myself but I think
I deserve everything yes thinking I know
my past and I have some of my what are
you saying some of my shame and my kilt
I think about that [ __ ] sometime and I
said Wow something must be okay his car
keep granny a lot of lessons yeah
something did he forgive me I did I'd
never forgave myself
yeah oh I think it always comes back to
that yeah you know the more I come to
understand spirit or higher power it's
all about you forgiving yourself at the
end of the day you know whatever it is
that you feel guilty or feel shame over
you know it's all about your
relationship to it and your attachments
within yourself to that you know well
who you have one of the best nicknames
in the game yeah who gave you the
notorious nickname the baddest [ __ ] um
that would be tricked $80 really yeah
I'm saying well at first use it the
baddest chicken it was so funny
earlier I was watching one of your music
videos and I've noticed that warrants
after that was my that actually was my
first music video on my solo album the
baddest chick album that's every year
and now I didn't really know much about
football but I I know I know Warren from
you know a couple people in Miami yeah
and so they're like oh we gonna use him
in the video I'm like okay good that's
cool now he's in the video but now they
want me to like walk over this guy's
Jersey which I guess his rivalry at four
yeah
yeah so that's how that was like how you
know that was just a funny moment for
having a video well you know at the time
I mean that was a big rivalry the pack
in the Buccaneers uh-huh but Warren he's
a big Miami guys that was funny to see
that yeah that's cool though yeah to
have that connection yeah or something
like that
your Tampa using Tampa no way you from
Miami you from Liberty City
you know convertible bird I love coming
I know that you know what that's the
first time I ever saw you in real life
is a convertible bird on 15th Avenue I
was a little little little girl saw me
yeah cuz my mom owned the store right
there and so you came to Miami he was
with him and I he was just you know the
biggest guy in Miami at the time and of
course now he was even the bigger
because you was there was a big old mom
and I just never I never forgot that
convertible bird convertible Bert yeah
player a player that's crazy
yep well tell us about growing up like
what word you you know how City Miami
nose is it's one of neighborhoods and
it's you know it back then in the time
when I grew up it was all about hustlers
all the hustles was I everybody was not
doing anything and it was you know who
had money money brought a lot of power
to the streets to the city my family was
real known so that's how my name just
became a popular figure this is so how a
new trick with the school with him and
and then I just you know I went on the
school trick in the book getting
arrested and we kind of separated for a
while and I just um I ran back into him
once I graduated school and once he came
out of prison and that's how the music
started and then from there the rest was
just history I started doing music I was
supposed to do real estate I went to
school to do real estate and trick
wanted me to do this record and once the
record I did a party for him when I did
the party he was like well you're just
gonna come hang out for my birthday it's
cool when I was like don't make me do
that song he was like no no no
and when I got into the party he played
the song and once he did his part every
girl knew the verse to the song and they
just started doing it he forced me on
the stage to do it and I hated him for
it and that's how the whole thing
started I saw made me really knew I
wasn't gonna do real estate I was gonna
do music and I just followed the path
Wow yeah I was that's a version of going
where the universe takes you yeah
absolutely
listen I had my first amateur fight
right
my first amateur fight I was just um I'm
so scared of course I was so nervous and
it was in a gym I'm really actually the
gym a small gym and I'm probably 70
people must became rain-filled the gym I
bring and I remember I knock the guy I
was so happy I fell on my feet I just
didn't know how to act I was so happy I
was on the floor I was crying I know the
dirt this is what I want to do yeah all
three I was 13 oh yeah okay so let me
ask a question at 13 okay cuz I have 13
s young so that's the difference but I
just have a hard hard time believing
that you were ever scared I never
stopped fearing you ever never in
notifies nothing never that's my biggest
one of my biggest qualities really yeah
we're but this is a fear book based
world that we live in more also if
they're afraid of failing we all say we
don't give a [ __ ] but we're afraid of
failing because be afraid of the
response we got to get from family my
criticism but still we say we don't give
a [ __ ] what people think about us you
know I mean we're born to care and I
wanna say the right words we were born
to care about what people think about us
because we have a ridge to improve
ourselves and we're mad at them because
I guess they're telling us to improve
ourselves and we don't want anybody to
tell us [ __ ] yeah he go you know that
check whatever it is that check of that
humbleness that they stressed upon you
is uh the urge to improve yourself well
should be urge for you to improve
yourself well you wanted to feel that
feeling again this is
area deplorable feeling yeah Mike when
Mike when I first we first started doing
this and Mike started opening up about
how scared he would be right before his
fights that just blew my mind absolutely
and I really related to its I played pro
football and you know the position I
played every day it was about you know a
hand-to-hand combat with another player
you know cuz I played offensive line and
every game I threw up before every game
in high school I know people do it would
take a [ __ ] before I would just throw up
I was so nervous you know because I had
that fear you know those butterflies
that anxiety about performing and it
always fueled me you know and so I
really related to that but what makes
more sense to me is how you know the
viciousness and the tenacity that you
saw in the ring with Mike that was him
unleashing that fear on that dude let's
no doubt about that there's no doubt
about that yeah absolutely
you know so however we can channel that
you know as performers because it's a
performance you know mm-hmm
that's just part of the deal I think you
know when you're young involved with
sports Ivica even be entertainment and
we're so we get so caught up in that we
forget how to love ourselves yeah and
sometimes we're we're not nice to
ourselves and we show it by being mean
to people you know yeah easy to get
caught up with you what you'd say if you
get caught but you there's no way you're
gonna love yourself but it's so easy to
get caught up with using your ego so
easy to believe we come from nothing we
come from trash
some of us got mothers and prostitutes
the father of pimps and then we get a
couple of life affirmations and thank me
with a card next time
that happened you know you get somebody
born from nothing and for my time a few
life affirmation somebody give him a
mentor and become a few words and all
sudden he gets confidence anything
[ __ ] God the understand I'm saying
kinda yeah where does that come from
like you how do you how do you get that
Eagle to go anyone or somebody just okay
it came from your mother your little boy
you playing with your friend hosting you
got that urge whether that come from
it's a life's journey of you know the
positives and the negatives of it yeah
have to be both in this kind of life you
know the negatives of the abuses you've
taken you know before you understand why
don't we why do we want respect why do
we feel that we need the respect what is
really respect what do we perceive this
respect you know you see people that
kill come on [ __ ] all my [ __ ] they
[ __ ] you or something like that I'm
gonna kill so what was what's the
concept of that what do you think I know
I'm already in deep I'm thinking so
you're saying why do people want respect
what do we think respect is yeah do you
think because of our history of who of
us black given we being treated so
disrespect for all i from the beginning
of us in this country do you think
that's our desperation for respect i
think most people because they don't
feel like they're worthy or anybody
unless they respect it unless i feel
like okay yeah if I see you I see eunice
tree hi how you doing that's respect or
I don't have to speak to you that's not
disrespect because I don't know you
I might not think that respect I might
think you need to sit you need to talk
long and the meaning is high I could
think that disrespected say hi how are
you how come people have different
illusions of themselves they think
they're plays without even passing any
test
you know talking to me and I agree you
know that's like if I'm somewhere and
someone takes X take a photo of me and
it's like oh cool I'll take the photo
but if you just go oh hey can I take a
photo and you don't even say hi how are
you how's your day or anything that's
almost just like I don't think that's
respect you don't even ask me how I'm
doing today it could be a horrible day I
could have almost got hit by the lyft
driver dropping me off and you're just
like let me get a photo let me get
forward I gotta go catch my flight it's
like you know so I I don't know we just
live in this fast crazy internet psychic
cycle driven where I think everybody's
like they is living in respect to being
a woman in the rap business oh no I feel
a certain I feel some I feel a certain
amount of respect but I don't feel as
respected as I need to be being a woman
that have always respected everybody
that I've worked and dealt around and
with whether this guy or women specially
guys I don't I don't feel dude I don't
get destroyed well it's a lot of
disrespect cuz I mean you no disrespect
comes in all forms like and it comes
from guys that come from somebody I've
dated somebody previously and you could
get mad I'm not dating them or not you
in the song are you saying some
disrespectful you saying that's
disrespect instead of just I don't cross
certain boundaries or just keep it
moving I feel like once you go now I'm
gonna target her now I'm gonna have some
sale now oh you this [ __ ] now
now that's disrespect you know and but
it happens it's the generation that we
live and it's a cycle that we portray
because all forms the type of music
people have so much to say oh however
they want to say whether it's music
sports however and we try to figure out
ways to deal with that or try to figure
out whatever and it's too many opinions
it's too many kinda we live in a world
of comments comments here everybody got
something to say they don't even know
what's really going on and they voice
their opinion and we all have one but I
think some like people don't understand
it or read the story Reading Is
Fundamental you don't dig into what's
happening just go judging oh I saw you
with this shirt on or whatever and oh I
saw you with Mike and something happened
just your story is gonna sound so crazy
than what really actually happened so I
don't know sometimes I just I look and I
see and observe everything that's going
on whether it's on the internet whether
it's social media it's in real life and
I don't really thinking that we just
like and throughout the matrix or
something yeah I don't know
it's almost like you think like really
what really happens after we die hit the
over like blank yeah what really does
but we'll never know that though that's
the scary thing about and even people
that you know that have gone away
you cannot say hey what's happening up
there where you're at what are you doing
you're chilling like are you smoking a
blunt on your the game cuz that not
happened I mean I would think that
should happen but it doesn't maybe it
does so we face a midnight I feel it's a
listen when I go into the toll like it's
this special medicine we take the total
this takes you to another dimension and
I when I wanted to told um I guess I I
don't feel anybody don't know anybody I
never met them anybody ever loved my
children everybody they don't want no
longer exist
really yeah say more about that Mike
because you said that before and it's
just that I'm curious I tell my wife
honey that Telemundo when she watched me
go unless I love you all praise be gone
long you know hit the whole thing right
and go I never know she exists she never
existed I never had a white bull oh yeah
you transcend that level of reality know
if I realized it's all about me it's all
about my journey I can't lift my at my
um my wife pain is not my pain I wanna I
want to comfort her pain but her pain is
not my pain I'm not gonna have a
miserable day because she's in a bad day
havin a bad day and stuff I'm gonna be
there to comfort all right my children
if things happen to my children I lose
my children whatever it's nothing I can
do we have to deal with the possibility
of the reality of loss of control
letting go such a suck reality sucks
yeah
when I think we haven't even faced it
yet the fact that listen dig this that
we all live in have we hanging out we
might leave here party whatever half the
best power but the actual reality is
it's almost over when I couldn't be here
much longer and it doesn't it's not
really long
but it's gonna seem like a long time
like 40 years if we make that matter how
far will be that long before we gotta
get sick we gotta get an accident mine's
gonna happen before we get to 40 days 40
years yeah it's almost over really and
what's really over because when you say
the next arrestor so what about the
generations coming the physical for us
but then what about the ones that still
are maybe two years old three so they
have time it's over for them so it's
over everybody is different my death is
not birth yes my birthday's are death
yes you know you know nobody's getting
out here raping it yeah but a free
ticket yeah we're gonna all experience
pain loss and then I think when it's
over we realize this just a joke I was
telling my friend and some police in
Nepal it's a little section a community
of monks and they all have a skull
headed there that room
you realize life is just a joke this is
where we're all gonna go at the end
gonna be skeleton bones and all that
[ __ ] you see things that are great about
us cuz I sure do I'm serving greatness
but I do understand what you're saying
because at the end of the day I don't
care who you are what success you've
reached how many concerts shows however
we are going into that same box space
however however it is before you go
there it would be so awesome and so
beautiful and unbelievable you went
there before you went do you get to know
who this is the person is yeah well my
mother and my father
they're just [ __ ] vessels in the
portals there's nothing there's nothing
about us that really our parents can
stop us for my joint come in at night
and [ __ ] you up staying out all night
dad mother and father we understand um
who's gonna tell us anything we don't
listen to we have to live our life
khalil gibran my life yeah you know yeah
one thing that comes to my mind is that
you know everyone has however much of
this is a feeling of not being worthy
you know to whatever extent it is you
know some people feel like they're they
don't even approve of themselves being
in the world you know they don't approve
of the thoughts that they have and what
people don't realize is that you know us
right here just being here just coming
into the world
you're already a manifestation of the
divine cosmos you're already a physical
representation of the universe you know
a fragment of God just as you are and
every thought that you have good and bad
god hears it and knows it and is already
forgiven you you know because it's
already done everything we do when
you're willing to just take steps and be
in action in your life and let the
universe take you and so getting over
that that feeling of unworthiness or not
being good enough that's a big step you
know it's a big move I don't know I
think it's just a battle a battle with
them too
I'll show you yourself that you are good
enough right and that's all up to you
it's all up to you cuz nobody else
I believe that under you know everything
is identified Jah we know with how many
you have the answer to all the questions
we want yes you know how many people
have told you how awesome you are you
know and how great you are and how much
success you've had and all the things
you know and you've been you know you
can when you get to that point when you
can buy whatever you want and it's not
enough no then my ego tells me you think
that those people fool I know you really
are or existence why are we here our
existence what the [ __ ] why do I think
I'm somewhere why do I think I'm a sly
[ __ ] who what would you know
where do you get that thought that's
what bother me why do you think that
it's a possible that you might be better
than somebody
who are you people people the people
that have always told you that or pushed
in your head or say it or always it's
constantly reminding you're saying that
I think and then it becomes habit for me
it's always been people that tell you
you were better than somebody or better
than everybody in the whole
entertainment of of your careers always
me you've always been the best nobody
could tell you anything or nobody could
stop we will argue that down to the day
we leave this earth and that's still
going to always be the argument you know
and I'm now personally no to say that
you some of those times like we're
scared I would never pick Chur the tool
you get but I get it because it's you
that's the in cipher so you are you know
and I understand that feeling because
I'm scared the same when I get on the
stage after a while want some in it that
little butterfly thing kind of move
around but at first I'm like this big ol
says all these people I don't want to
fall in these hills and I want something
to go Raj it's like it's be so many
things happen at one time but I get that
and I were you thinking like it's the
only mistake you got going on looking
good yes I mean that's some [ __ ] already
just doing that in heels
yeah biggest you don't want to fall
you're gonna make sure I fell once by
mistake I never I never felt in my whole
entire career I don't know something
happen with a stage this guy right here
with the ball here he ran on stage first
he said one two through the mic and I it
was my cue to come on I come - and after
him one two he go one two three and he
falls I go one two three my cue and I go
right and fall after him that was the
most horrible thing I didn't understand
how to happen the same time but that's
the only time I fail these guys all
these guys are my Ghazi from Miami
Google Google his real name is actually
Google or Google
that's Raymond and that's CEO back there
in the cut love doing this [ __ ]
traveling with her and [ __ ] mean people
come to is hanging out he takes photos
and videos and other stuff is a whole
different world I was born in 94 yeah
well you were boxer like Google wasn't
even found a year and that was in 98 I
saw like your biggest fights was like
before Google was founded so like me
growing up and being able to even like
know about you and actually being able
to think of myself like that
oh look at that Oh keep it 100 we all in
here just shoot like everybody walks in
us all like four cuz that's that that's
that that's what the that's the aura
think about myself I look at pictures of
myself as a teenager I'm watching myself
as I get older in my twenties I start
fighting and I have to [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
is this guy why the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
just glad you know I was talking in my
partner and I was saying regardless of
everything I'm talking about slavery the
worst thing never happened the world the
Holocaust everything this is a beautiful
world yeah because everything evil ever
happened in this world this world is
beautiful how you know me if I know
account um the good eye way too bad in
this world you know I mean the good by
far way too bad if we had light always
kill a war and we always decimated that
[ __ ] the idea that we actually lived
and had an awesome life that over that
supersedes everything yeah what do you
guys think when you come in and you meet
my
some [ __ ] like wow lady was
everybody was thinking like what could
see I mean this is our first time to
like and this is we're having a
conversation but in our view and vision
all we are all our whole viewer vision
is just the greatest that's you don't
even see that's the first thing come to
picture is that this the greatest
fighter of all times of all times in the
history of fighting
well I knew like that's Albany we don't
see nothing else you don't know anything
else no out like I remember they're
making a big scandal about your tattoo
on your face like and now and like
honestly I liked when you did it I
didn't see nothing wrong with it because
it was like you you're your own person
like you do what you want to but I feel
like you open doors for people that do
it now because people wouldn't be doing
that now if you were never did that
could be interesting cuz sometimes I
look at people with okay to the hood a
15th Avenue a convertible Bert everybody
in Miami knows that and I was like a
little young little little little girl
and everybody around him my whole family
knew and knew him and that's like the
biggest thing of my real personal friend
of mine I've been hurt since what 87 88
right so we've been hanging out for a
while since we both went to went away
and we both came back and um you always
kept in touch I've been keeping in touch
and since he's been in prison he's been
and the [ __ ] Miami
what's that safe house you go before you
get halfway houses they're half a mile
if you had to bring them food that
brought him food there yeah
when I met Mike I was just blown away by
his humility in his heart you know and
how much love he had the guy gave me a
hug the first time I met him I was like
this is that [ __ ] new people I know
dude but it's just you know I don't know
what you expect when you're reading you
know Hercules you know what I mean
because that's what it's like man you're
like Greek mythology
that's cool and it is cool it's just
like you know meeting you and getting to
know you and hang out with you has been
such a lesson you know for me in my life
of humanity you know and what we can
work to achieve and the people that we
can still be you know and the people
that we can become and it's awesome
there yeah that's why I think I do this
stuff yeah I do this Joe I want to
become something yeah well I once was
yeah you are man you know you're
everything everything listen nobody's
gonna escape right life is gonna live
you yeah well whatever escape life
that's another gem life is no one's
gonna escape life life is gonna live you
it's true man Alyssa how do you escape
you can stay in your house 24 hours a
day you how did you escape it you're
gonna fall down the stairs one day you
know something's gonna happen you can't
escape it you have to live it yeah yeah
that's facts okay Trina what's your fate
what has been your favorite part like
what really what gets you up in the
morning about being a rapper and being
in music and doing what you do I would
say mostly uh-huh just how it makes me
feel it's been good times it's been
horrible times and then I think for me
the connection with the fans I have like
real diehard fans so it's been times
when I was like trying to do my album I
trying to do music and I was just like
I'm not enough mode of feeling it and I
was just looking at some of the stuff
they would say and just some of the
reasons they would say you know how I
inspired him or why all these different
things and in my mind I was like I still
have to feel it connecting here like it
has to be a purpose I have to want to do
it I have to want to do this album in
these terms because now when I do it I
want to talk about these things that's
happened in my life current and you know
it had to all make sense for me so I
just think I'm you know when I wake up
sometimes I'm in a mood and I'm my whole
mind is music because I have so much to
say I want to talk about it that's what
I call this venting you know when I go
into the studio and then there's times
when it's like
down and I think I'm gathering it up
trying to figure it out because like you
say like life is really happening it's
real every single day and sometimes in
you know in this field like for me and
music okay when we're in a club while
I'm doing shows that's in a club that's
partying but that's not life to me
that's just the fun part like I don't go
I like to I mean I works when I'm out
and party and that's one thing but
that's not what drives me once I'm done
with that and it's like over yagi synced
in so now I got a deal with okay how do
I feel now how do I feel tomorrow do I
feel like recording do I feel like
making music what is the movement am i
said am I happy am i experiencing
something going through anything that I
want to divulge and talk about in this
music so be just like a bunch of
different things but it do you have your
card up a lot
sometimes the untrustworthy of people
sometimes oh absolutely I think for me
right now I'm in a situation that's with
a very untrustworthy situation I think
has got me very guarded and you know
when you do business with people you
know you its business about for me I
think respect and Trust you know being
truthful and when you find out things
that you know people have done this not
truthful it kind of puts you in between
like your back against the wall do you
live in your truth or do you remove
yourself from the situation you know and
all in total so I think I'm in I'm
feeling that very much that that
situation this very moment oh that's
really interesting yeah whenever I find
myself in a situation like that where
I'm like this isn't working for me I
feel I start to feel crazy like I'm
gonna go crazy like I'm gonna snap you
know and I'll go through the process of
why am I in this situation why has life
done this to me etc and say oh yeah it's
just on me you know it's just on me like
I can just remove myself from the
situation you know you know even though
we have partners and we have people that
we love in life this is the individual
journey yeah when we go meet god animate
he's not
you know what happened to your wife or
your kids it's honest actually about
your deeds and what we did or whatever
we did you know yeah that's why I found
that by taking everything's an
individual path the toad because I want
to make sure I'm clear here's the toad
it's a this is a little Idol of it a
little statue of it but the toad it's an
animal the toad and they extract its
venom and in its venom is this stuff
five Meo DMT and DMT is a psychedelic
chemical compound that we produce in our
brains and they say we get a hit of it
naturally in our life when we come into
being in our mother's womb and then on
our deathbed so some people think that
maybe it's the portal of the soul into
the physical realm so you can smoke it
when you extract the venom from this
toad they dry it crystallizes you scrape
it up and then you can smoke it and you
have a 15 to 20 minute experience of God
you have an ego death you know you are
released from much of your trauma and
pain you get a lot of information in a
really quick time and very quick quick -
quick - quick get to put and people have
really transformative experiences on it
so you know people who are dealing with
addiction they come out and they're no
longer addicted to whatever does heroin
or whatever
here's depression anxiety you know
because it goes to you know the pearl
essence of the things that we as
individuals hold on to that unknowingly
create mechanisms in our lives
mechanisms of thought so that you know
the things that bother us the things
that you know rub us the wrong way the
resentments we carry the anger we hold
these all have an origin in us and so
the toad goes in there and it basically
shows you that actually our guests
yesterday linked up something for me
which was really interesting it takes
you back into these experiences and it
shows you them without any ego so you
can allow yourself to be released
you can't imagine being being without
thinking the patters but you can't
imagine not having your guard up Kenya
you can't think about thinking mother
[ __ ] what you looking at I could imagine
that having that you because I'm so
afraid I'm so afraid that people might
find again I'm I'm really a little
scared boy and I was a loser and always
wanted to be at somebody and I tried too
hard and I was desperate so I was tough
for me [ __ ] question my
masculinity had nothing yeah so when you
take the toad you confront all that
you're not gonna win you don't have you
know you don't know what you know you're
gay straight you don't know what you're
scared scared scared wholly scared
nothing you don't see none but you're
scared the feelings blow off the hook
anything from the first moment of your
life you saw all those feelings it's
powerful that super power you might
think you're God yeah yeah yeah I think
you got the right thing you ever gonna
come to God this is gonna be the clothes
and you're not gonna come close to
anything no cocaine no heroin that can't
even come close nothing can come close
mushrooms nothing you on drugs now you
take this you never take the drug
against a [ __ ] we're gonna take this
tomorrow tonight again and I never
thought listen I've been all over the
world I've been all over the world a
couple of times I've did everything the
great women great cars great houses
great boat great path everything and so
I've been there's no way I could tell me
[ __ ] about nothing I'm a Queens King
[ __ ] czars I met everything
[ __ ] and then I took the toad I
found I ain't no [ __ ] I ain't never did
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ] Wow
this will talk ain't [ __ ] ain't do
nothing nothing I didn't I didn't know
who I was I do [ __ ] I'll let it dip I
didn't know who I was so I did nothing I
did nothing not a [ __ ] thing and I
thought it was a fly [ __ ] what a joke
well you still got a lot nah I have two
toes I know what you're saying but you
know I didn't do me yeah I did
everything else to disguise Who I am
interesting I want anybody else to think
of this guy but you know I never wanted
to touch this this is scary stuff
we can't even knock that down that
inspiration that cuz I mean we've seen
it's it's it you can't erase the history
it's there like people grew up we lived
we that's all we know we can why do we
do that stuff though why do we want to
do that stuff do we hide our shame to
our success
people won't question that's because
they were so successful they won't
question you know they don't have no
idea what that is yeah
and I'm noting what you saw yeah cuz I
had all that money and I didn't know
what I doing I didn't think I deserved
it what the [ __ ] am i doing all this
I'm from [ __ ] my parents are pimps and
hoes the [ __ ] I'm doing all the same and
power will stop please leave me alone
[ __ ] all you leave me a [ __ ] yeah no one
teach you how to prepare for this [ __ ]
no preparation is just like well no one
probably could have prepared you for
that you know cuz no one very few people
have even been that hot you know to that
mountaintop you know it's weird stuff
and I mean our illusion of ourselves you
know every time we talk about this
you've gone a little deeper you've
gotten some more insights but that was
really interesting then you know that
point of I never I wasn't doing me yeah
absolutely that's what I read about so I
was so good at history I read about so
many personality that was those guys
I'll never meet I was afraid of me I'm
nobody Mike Tyson from Brownsville
Brooklyn that's nobody [ __ ] that but
if I'm [ __ ] I am Mike I'm a
[ __ ] my Annihilator and
everybody knows it
so it's always about the my illusion of
myself what am I really do you think
we've never talked about it but you
talked about it on Joe Rogan's when cus
had you hypnotized yeah do you think a
lot of it came after that did that hold
for you for a long time lately hell's to
me now how old were you and you're
hypnotized I started at 14 and what
would it be
it's a lactation blissing it and an
affirmation of destruction and eloquent
destruction that may get your lead
[ __ ] you know it's a
sophisticated lease plan this our New
England
the world and the world's gonna know our
name and you're gonna be a god
people who name their children after you
they have a champion named Tyson fairy
yeah
listen they told me everything then plea
but then he was telling you that
everything happened well that's what
after that's what we do we're all
products of our thoughts yeah who we
think we are I mean we become even if we
start out poor we become that person
before we become successful and then we
become successful with all our [ __ ]
thoughts
I sometimes gonna have a good opinion of
myself but I love Who I am isn't that
weird is that well I'm gonna pee myself
I love Who I am
sometimes yeah yeah are you saying you
loved I love Who I am at the time Iron
Mike no I'm saying that now okay
everything all my flaws everything I
love wearing that makes me who I am
I love Who I am because I can be no one
could be Who I am
no no why I ran away from myself so long
I thought I was ugly I didn't think I
had anything interesting say it talk
about myself no yeah the craziest thing
is that you know see cuz say for
instance if we weren't here face to face
and just we had this was just some
person with their story and what their
interpretation of you is then now the
world is thinking or listening or to
what another person's view is or however
they paint the picture but to be in your
presence and then the way you feel or
how you speak and how you say and see
things and view it it's so more surreal
and different you know like it's it's
never it's never great unless it's
coming from the person that like you
said like a person can look at you and
have all these things but they don't
know you they don't know anything you
not only say that that's the most thing
that feels like that's a real I know how
that feel like you know what I mean like
I would never sit here and think um that
you were this way yeah yeah like very
deep very smart very very
yeah I do like the inventory it's still
about inventory because my past you have
my past yeah not for my path to do a lot
of inventory because I'm from my past I
was a megalomaniac and from my path I
don't give a [ __ ] about your feelings
uh-huh and now when I became conscious
of those hurting people feel that to go
up in polynomial have to apologize yeah
so when you say you didn't you'd wasn't
conscious realize you did it that was
why because you just know my my wife my
kids everybody
you just think care because why you were
angry or you just Mike I don't care I
have to feel no way why is it that I'm
listen to them the reason that we have
all this because of me okay am i
listening to them I love them but
they're not saying I'm the one who made
this happen the pose I have to depend on
them to make this happen
where would I be living I'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that and then now you gotta
apologize oh yeah I go now you gotta
apologize and it's like so it made you
think and you're like what I might be a
mean or at work no he's mine security we
share my guilt maybe I've cheated or
something me but I'm thinking about
cheating [ __ ] so I make them
insignificant in my mind if I can't have
my pleasure [ __ ] you know it's just hard
to deal with how do you do with your
selfishness we also may not feel free
but when you explain what Celsius is
with your [ __ ] up selfish how do you
deal with that stuff it's such a bad
[ __ ] but it's such a self-preservation
instinct I think that's one of those
things that as you become more mindful
and you wake up and you're more
conscious about the people around you at
turn you know you know what I learned
I'm 53 but no I know I ran if I get
older as I get it I worry what God's
gonna do to me about the [ __ ] that I did
and I never told nobody and I only know
[ __ ]
he knows ya know he knows already
yeah I know he knows but then when you
get older you really know he knows and
it doesn't go away sick [ __ ] I'm dying
he's gonna [ __ ] be mad at me
you think so huh you think so do you
think he's probably like well you know
you're good over where you're bad so I'm
gonna forgive you don't look at it like
I always look at that come from my ego
perspective yeah I'm gonna see God when
I die yeah I'm gonna meet God [ __ ]
God is I think I feel I know I exist
it's probably only my mind my
relationship with God
my relationship is going cotton which
you gonna be a blackout [ __ ]
Ilyas be blackness ain't gonna be no
heavenly clouds and [ __ ] [ __ ]
gonna be a black night
cars gonna look after me why would God
looks after you why is it that you know
we all did a bunch of bad [ __ ] why is it
when we did I bastion within close to
the god god forget for everything but
God didn't forget when we were murdering
how do think about this how does the guy
who dies in prison like he has life and
he does like this 55 60 years in prison
and he died what does he think he's
going to go no I don't know where he go
he may go thinking is mine yeah exactly
I think that is will but look what
torment does he go through in his mind
does he wish she's dead that come fast
enough it depends I guess but deaf have
to be fascinating because rifles
fastening how could definitely be
fascinating it's a part of life
well I don't think so I just think that
I don't know what happens at I don't see
I'm a little different I start believing
all kinds of other stuff that may seem
weird and then everybody says oh there's
life after death
yeah says who because once you're out of
here
once you out of here whatever you spear
all that stuff whatever it's gonna go
this whole physical thing all this
you're never gonna see that again and
the people that that's before you can
never tell you that whatever's happened
to ever there we may not be nobody know
where everybody's just blacked on it's
all gone it's over and that's just the
end of it I think it's just a myth of
just the same thing like Christmas and
the Easter Bunny and all the rest of
those fairy tales that's what I believe
what about the people that have been
dead for 20 or 30 minutes and came back
that's probably just that's from I
believe in like I don't know the name of
it like I'm almost I'm finding so
leaving a body stuff almost like I
almost he was on life support whatever I
don't know I forgot the name of it um
yeah I believe in that short minute but
I don't believe like once you're gone
gone gone you're not coming back and
they do the removal of remains it's over
I was there I've been through some stuff
I witnessed I see some stuff I'm a it's
a different thing I just don't I think
it's after that it's a disconnect I
don't know your soul your spirit I mean
but the spirit doesn't have a face or
anything so it's just what a bunch of
like air running around speaking of
hanging out with people around the rest
of the world or wherever set or you
bring your ancestors from the ground I I
don't I just be trying to figure out
where does everything happens after the
physical or some people going to ground
I think I made like some difficult
complex but okay yeah but didn't create
a God who eat what is a like God is what
though woman me go testicle that's the
male testosterone thing that's legal
there's the women with their
vulnerability that thinks it's a woman I
just feel a feeling I don't really want
to face it or say it's a face or
whatever man woman I don't know what are
these skull pictures and all that stuff
I don't think none of that stuff is
realistic I think it's all the amount of
what you believe in which maker that's
why we have so many different people
that believe in different spirituality
religions and all kind of stuff and if
it was one thing one person everybody
believe in the same thing they don't and
they cannot because we have too many
different spiritual people that believe
in totally different things but it's all
the thing hmm the same way everything we
live in Christianity Buddhism Islam
yes the Indian religion faith would but
get that it's all the same it's all the
same yeah it's all this all the struggle
good and evil
that's what ups and downs adversity
coming back from failure overcoming
gluttonous eating yourself to death
control sacks addict drug addict passion
addict so hate addict I think it's
everything
me too
have you ever met someone for the first
time and thought I know this person what
do you mean like just seeing her face oh
I know him more like I have this more
and more these days actually oh I
noticed person and I meet someone for
the first time and I know I've never met
him before in this life hmm
but I'm like I know this person I think
that's happened to me before
how do you explain that I don't know cuz
I don't know it's almost like somebody
saying that somebody's been here before
they remind you of somebody before
something in the past past tense or
whatever I don't know where that comes
from or how what makes you feel that but
it's just the weird feeling but it
happens a lot
I don't know if it's a person's energy
to wear the egg it could remind you of
you know all that energy yeah call it
energy you know listen I'm gonna taste
that happen I was on a plane I was in
Europe somewhere listening I was um I
was partying back then so I was
finishing my mother three-month thing
and I'm south of France so I I got
caught up in I was in demo then I got
caught up in Sweden someone and I was
talking to a guy and this guy says how
you doing mr. sikes I'm a big fan and I
think he said my name is Cosmo I yeah
right like cargo de Michi like the
middie he said yes that's my name and he
pulled out that was his name [ __ ] you
know cuz he has a famous name name was
famous last year right like Arden would
meet you right yeah the minute yeah
that's my name how did you know and that
was his name I bet you if he ever sees
this he parks it yeah that was me
that was so weird is not crazy that's
crazy and this is the old reminisce on
rich family banker family back in the
day and I said I knew that when he said
Cod ladies not steak house moved amici
and it's my name did you talk to him at
all for few minutes
did you hear elated I didn't want to ask
you that then that means he's very
wealthy and people are uncomfortable
paying who they are
he probably would have talked to you you
were like come on with mine it's mine
when I said that I hope he's watching
this oh he looks at this that did that
Cosmo to Michi yeah de MIDI you know
buddy you know rich families yeah it
leads to bankers wow that's a trip I
mean I don't know I I believe that
there's definitely something behind all
of it but no one else happens there
funny like you think about for mine he
calls yeah how can you control that make
them call you whenever you want them to
yeah you know you think about they call
those you think about somebody next
thing you know they pull up Mexico
something that synchronicity how do we
control that how can so what we could do
it whenever we want to who do we want
who do we want to bring in bull many
comes in you know me who do we want and
hit the Pope the Pope yeah Darley Lima
Pope the Pope let's just visualize it
see it all right they'll be here soon
yeah that the bet in Lima one of those
guys did that'd be cool man be
interesting I don't you know I I think
it's interesting that these you know
enlightened people like the Dalai Lama
he hasn't really done a whole lot
physically you know he hasn't had a
whole lot of experiences you know so how
do you get to that point of knowing if
you haven't experienced much of real
life but that's what I wanted to talk to
him about I wanted to ask them why do
you feel
by being chafed that's going to improve
you hmm
are you want to be improved as a human
being I'm one cool team and being or do
you want to reach God status and by
doing it do you just want to let go of
everything and that's what it is relief
right of everything it's a complete
letting go yeah that's interesting when
you say letting go meaning like say it
what do you mean by it
everything God I'm with God does
everything anything man-made there's
nothing to make nothing about oh you
know what's interesting because there
was this girl that was a friend of mine
really nice girl and she started going
through some real bad personal life
changes and she has a son and I saw her
for like I was in Atlanta she came to me
I was at a restaurant she came to visit
me and she really went deep into like
you know life has got I guess the best
of her so bad so what she's letting go
of everything like what you just saying
is exactly what's happening to her life
and it kind of scared me away from her
because it started becoming like that
give me - yeah it she I pushed away from
her so bad because she just kept saying
the world is over this life we live
everything that God is coming guys so
she was I must say well your people your
friends your family anybody around you
everybody have to know that God is
coming back all this stuff that she was
saying it was so deep and so much I
think I was like yeah I get it but hello
I got to go to work I got he's like
everything is none of that matters is
she went until she flipped to a whole
nother thing and I broke our friends or
her because I got so scared
listen Aries check this out okay right
now right you we have a lot of things
like this is um distracting us we gotta
leave go here you gotta go someplace um
yeah do some other things on phone this
is distracting but yes think you're
doing so much but just think for one
moment very shortly
imagine thinking um you won't exist no
more your voice won't you won't hear
yourself talk no more and that's word on
the physical house after that you won't
no longer
and let drive people insane when they
come down at whoa this guy won't really
exist I'm getting older you know and God
prepares you for death you might get
accident you hurt your back start
getting older you get impotent you don't
like sex no more lot of your friends
start passing away things what the [ __ ]
am I here for you know the fact that you
don't long exist some place that you've
been accustomed to for a certain amount
of time though you know and now it
doesn't exist it doesn't matter anymore
now where am I going with her like what
happens I'm existing now even though my
body I feel I'm dying but I feel like
I'm going somewhere else where am I
going and that drives people insane the
fact the actual rights to think of life
drives people insane that I won't exist
no more life is all about me all I do is
think about me how this knowledge just
no more is that frightening enough this
what's going on with me right now so
long as one like this one day that's all
I think about is myself
I think I'm granting myself how could I
die I'm think I'm cause some type of
[ __ ] car I'd die you know but the
reality is you're gonna be out of here
soon buddy thank you well that really
scares well the ego gets really scared
you know the ego is attached to like Who
I am what I do I have you know I owe I'm
responsible for a lot of people I'm
responsible for you know these things
that I do I have a job I've you know a
family and so all of that identification
all of those things that we hold on to
that's what you know the Dali Lama or
Buddhism or you know this idea of
letting go it's about cutting all the
attachments you know to all these things
and that's really scary for the ego you
know now I would think if I never took
the toad if I never kind quote quote you
know understanding of the light Middle
East I won't say I'm in right but to
understanding of it I would be dying
well be [ __ ] my wife Oh God
I'll be [ __ ] my wife in kilos you get
a [ __ ] my money but now listen oh [ __ ]
hood it's all good okay
get the [ __ ] and I say to myself maybe
that's because I [ __ ] around on my
so-called quote friend's wife or
girlfriend maybe that's gonna come back
to me too you know you always think
about things you thought you got away
with stuff that think you really get
away never get away cuz stick sticks to
you yeah you go don't let it get away
yeah yeah guys got it the worst you guys
really have done a lot of stuff you know
you've gotten away wait so you know that
it's [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] up yeah sheesh
well that's why I'm of the Divine
Feminine
the deal is that never um you never you
can't hide from yourself you know where
to [ __ ] go no I didn't think of the
state of our country and the president
of all of that stuff it's just I'm lost
that what's happening now at first I was
kind of paying attention to following up
but at this point I think um yeah I just
think it's just the whole total just
people up and a lot of people you know
that that was so you know non-political
don't think your vote matter don't want
to do this don't want to put the effort
for it to make sure your voice is heard
these other people that's wreaking it
the most because now you have so much to
say and you know all this stuff when you
did not even care put the effort in to
make sure your voice is heard then so
now you have this president that's doing
all these weird crazy strange ridiculous
things and it's so much bad happening
like so much it's that's one thing to
deal with but when you have the war you
have the Walmarts getting shot up all
different restaurants all of these
people that people are just insanely
going nuts for what what is driven you
inside of your mind to think that it's
okay to walk in a public place full of
kids and people and just do this how
many people do that
when I reach a certain age um I've been
told all my life who I am
because of who I am I'm gonna succeed in
life and I reached that point in life
where I should be successful and I'm not
success okay we'll do it to kill
yourself don't take out a whole gang no
no I'm not gonna kill myself because the
world lied to me I'm gonna kill the
[ __ ] world but innocent kids it
doesn't know look at me look at me I'm
nothing I'm nothing the world lied to me
I'm supposed to be somebody yeah so why
should they survive why should they be
happy I'm not happy okay do you feel
like that would be how I guess if the
world lied in certain certain aspects
but what part of it to yourself as a
person that you feel so low and you're
not prospering to what you want to do or
be in life till you say hey this is not
working out this karidian work this job
didn't work this girl didn't wear
whatever didn't work I got to figure out
something for me to make me feel happy
or you just go through what you're like
me how do you think yeah in that ration
of the hope that's a rational thinking
that I rational make that big feeling of
oh it's over my life is over I'm not
lost the [ __ ] job my girlfriend left
me she took my kids holy [ __ ] I'll never
get another girl that laughing at me oh
my god [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody I'll show
them I'm a man nobody won't laugh at me
ideal of what a man is is confusing to a
lot of people yeah what is it man I
don't know you know I know what do you
physically you know I can I can identify
what a man looks like you know I don't
know what isn't man I don't know what I
am it's not what we've been taught
that's for sure no so can you break the
untaught abou cycle like say for
instance if you were a kid and you grew
up and you didn't have a dad or a father
so now you are you probably not so out
of ten don't since you didn't have that
father now you have a kid so you didn't
really learn much because you didn't
have a dad so now you're trying to
figure it out yourself how to teach your
kid and some parts may not be me failure
may not meet up to the standards or
whatever that may be does that make you
feel like where you're testing yourself
in my man am I doing this right why am i
making sure my wife is good my house is
good my kids again or am I happy with my
job am i happy with my weight my bike
all of these things
um you know that's us that's us in our
own head but God takes care tomorrow
tomorrow's gonna be here but are we
gonna be here for tomorrow
right yeah we have to prepare for
tomorrow yeah to prepare that um reach
our highest potential for tomorrow you
know we don't have much time you know
that's not what we're here for him you
know reach our highest potential could I
look at myself would you think a year
ago was the junkie I was old Dean I was
doing like drugs this my life was over
and my [ __ ] mind and pull my get this
company big company living life like a
[ __ ] it's just [ __ ] crazy you know
I mean and all I do is just um have
gratitude you know I have gratitude you
know that [ __ ] that laughter I
definitely think I was somebody that I
wasn't you have to have fun you know
gratitude to really know that this is
all from God I was steering this [ __ ] I
be on crack I have AIDS or something if
I was steering this ship my ship loads
I'm [ __ ] behind a that [ __ ] in the
hospital with the [ __ ] [ __ ] so that's
why I know this is bigger than me I stay
out of my own way on Seychelles don't do
that [ __ ] like [ __ ] [ __ ] you down say
[ __ ] no more in myself and see what
happens yeah Trina do you have time are
you good on time or you have to all
right yeah we go are we going to Miami
we have a movie premiere tomorrow oh wow
that's awesome
yeah what do you want when this is all
over like you see when Holly now and
people on me asking I do 25 minus all
Alleva what do you want to do what what
image you want to see what's your
illusion of when it's over for myself
you know yes yeah we finished if you
ever want to finish yeah for me I'm cool
with just being at peace I'm cool with
just being me regular just in a space
where it doesn't
I'm not confined to this I'm not
confined cool with being on an island
somewhere just with my shoes off and
just be
regular randomly just ed up in a great
space I've done a lot seeing a lot
travel a lot did everything I'm not
fascinated by the tangible things we
have around cuz I look at this it's it's
none of that matters in the in our I
understand that I just want to be just
like in the you know mentally peacefully
like just you know I think that's like I
don't know because I've I have I don't
really understand that I've really ever
been that puppy I mean with your
occasional Reno which were you just just
wanna crazy but were you get an adult I
think I don't I don't think I've
experienced that because my I mean life
is it's happy it's sad it's emotion is
chaos is work is this is all these
things in one so I'm not sitting here
thinking I need to find this balance I
think about it now I haven't thought
about it before you know so I know when
it's done I don't want to be sitting at
home long to the internet trying to keep
up with what's going on in the world
that I'm peacefully I'm away from I just
what I have my time myself my life Mike
you know how do you get a [ __ ] on
Tremec on how do you do that Treena time
I look at you know you got somewhere to
go
I know go back to my trainer time all
week I go to Miami don't move from here
I go from there to a concert to country
love it yes yeah Treena time is that
place of that's a part of love that's a
part of when I just want to be free from
all of this everything all the just
whole whatever if my imperfections
everything about me everything I'm going
through if I'm have the number one
record on the chart so I have no records
on the charts that's when I do my free
time that's no makeup nothing during
Mass sure nothing dramatic just just
being in the space of just being content
with who I am you know just being good
at that space it like and I I'm that's
the place that I want to be it I'm at my
best when I'm not thinking about me you
are yeah
yeah who are you thinking about God
really yeah
anything but me yeah maybe because
you've always been your best all your
life excuse me maybe because you've been
your best all your life no I don't think
that is my perception of myself was
never my better what with which is
interesting I've always had to come back
I could never be um Michael everything's
going good yeah you're thinking this
chill so nASA has a sentence worth
giving all this dozens worth getting my
[ __ ] awesome girlfriend family son
gotta be worth more because my
girlfriend or some girlfriend and a
family say don't ever talk to that [ __ ]
again you know cut the [ __ ] that I'm
doing so I'm I'm gonna saying what the
[ __ ] I always keep myself in the [ __ ]
and I it's always put myself back in the
situation I said [ __ ] you know I've been
trying to kill myself every time just
decided to see what happens if I let
this try to live you know see what
happens
oh yeah crazy world who's your
girlfriend on the show on the show um
it's really just me get my cousin Joy
um I hang out with the most and a couple
girls I don't really hang out with so
many people on the show mm-hmm yeah just
kind of my family mostly gay guy Bobby
Bobby Bobby that's my friend Bobby likes
Bobby vicariously lives to me he's just
happy that we've had so much yeah he
does he does he's cool though he's
drinking he's a wild crazy guy and he's
very flamboyant and very very very much
out there that's funny
how is it how is it on Love & hip-hop me
is kind of cool because I don't really
have that much drama so I'm just kind of
like whatever I got going on in life I'm
in a studio on record and I'm traveling
I'm doing a concert I'm hanging out with
Bobby it's just mostly like stuff that
actually is happening uh-huh and you
know I kind of don't be on the scenes
with a wild stuff happening so I kind of
get away from that yeah think I'll take
her you'll get boom so the guys from
now they got some business to do so
their classes the new people the
interacting hang out with them get
information do whatever it got to become
where they were all the shows meet
everybody all the Heather will show with
everybody all because we can't get P in
Miami no more altogether is it like that
yeah no not yet not sure I mean they
gotta bring Mike and to consult on that
[Laughter]
[ __ ] job yeah watching and otherwise
that I see that my old girlfriends are
far I could do this show too
[Laughter]
oh my god well you got a show coming
right I was gonna be so awesome
you don't like rolling with the punches
it's gonna be about Mike and guarding
this comfort on this company over you
that I'm finished box and I'm [ __ ] up
and starting this cannabis company Mike
absolute got a bunch of guys in here we
on Peters Russell Peters gonna be with
us what the moon we got a bunch of
people yeah a lot great cast
how do they feel about you the stuff
they like you yeah you don't mean to
sound everywhere in the south you get
some little peanuts yeah the Minnie's
right mini version yeah all the time
every time
[Laughter]
the baddest man on the planet that's
right podcast we do is we smoke here how
much bone only phone how much we smoke
forty forty thousand pounds a month yeah
forty thousand pounds a month or forty
pounds Oh forty pounds a month yeah
forty thousand
no he's 40 pounds we said 40,000 pounds
another episode I think on the way we do
a month a week 40 pounds 40 pounds I
smoked a little weed and got my numbers
mixed up okay yeah it's all good man
well anything else going on that you
want wanted to know before we head out
yeah you guys you can follow me on Trina
Rockstar with two hours on ige social
media Twitter all these social sites my
album is out the one I'm excited I'm
features videos everything coming out
yeah I have a label um I I did do don't
this world is crazy I don't know about
thinking about now you said a kid and I
start thinking about hmm now you gotta
be responsible for this human being for
18 years until it's an adult or
projectors are right and then after that
and then after that what it whatever
they I don't know whenever I'm no longer
in this presence this this here then
what I'm worried about do my kid is out
here I don't know I'm just nervous I was
gonna take care of imagine this it's bad
enough that we're not gonna exist no
more now we're not gonna leave anything
behind
yeah but can we exist any kind of way
ego gotta just some way at least
something wrong nope I don't have no
kids
money don't have no key there you go
that's a small percentage that's well
what if you leave behind a lot of great
energy yeah I'm just uh that's probably
my ego people gotta be but I gotta be if
sure it's just disasters thinking you
know do you yeah you have do you have
boy or girl keys I got both my girls and
boys really your sons are how big would
I have three boys that were eight year
old I was six seventeen year old man for
22 years so do you ever feel they feel
pressured because your your status your
life is so huge like gigantic to the
world but to you you tell them they're
just dad
you just say dad but like do you ever
feel like oh I got the pressure I gotta
be the best person I gotta because my
dad was like the king no that's on yum
really but when I say that because like
okay we live in this world so bullied is
so everybody and just imagine like if a
kid have that pressure because the world
has that pressure like you're the
greatest so now your kid has this thing
like I don't want to fail my dad I got
to be the greatest I need to be in light
you know hey that's his struggle he have
to deal with my objective was be a
better parent than my parents were to me
sometimes my kid complain but you know
imagine they had my father yeah did he
beat up pretty bad yeah I mean they'd
never been hitting stuff in their life
dealt with that great life with the
great schools and stuff or that private
tutors and all that stuff's nice house
that gets a pampered life and I don't
they got that but they have to figure
something out you know I mean they have
to figure it out we all have to figure
it out I'm not gonna be here long
we really think about this thing another
twenty thirty I'm not gonna be they
gotta figure this [ __ ] out you know I
mean I rather give my money to charity
this my kids are not on top of their
game psychologically and mentally you
know I give them some money to karyn's
up and break them off like I already go
to charity and then what is charity
gonna do with it huh
what's charity gonna do with it more
than what I was doing it really yeah
what a guy like me with ego to undo it's
a month maybe your wife can handle it
yeah yeah we think well okay well see
they see the charity not too nice to
give away yeah there's some good
charities out there yeah you know doing
some good work
figure it out can you say why do you
give charity why are you want people to
think that you especially could use and
what does charity a form of guilt and I
really know one thing why do people get
cherry well why do you think I should
get some charity oh I should mean Who am
I to think that these people need
something and I'm the one who need to
give it to them and I'm the only one
that can solve their problem like I'm
from who the [ __ ] am I I'm well I was
worse than them and I got lucky
so now I think I know their problems and
not to help them well it's good to give
yeah you know and you can you can argue
and debate all day what's you know what
does that mean you know to give Who am I
to give charity
nobody said why do people want people to
know hey I've gave these people a
hundred million now look at me
I think because it's innate that giving
feels good you get a lot out of giving
you know and if you're somebody who has
a lot of money to give you probably feel
pretty good about yourself so that could
be an ego trip yeah you know but you
know guys like like we had that talk
with Trey the truth remember cuz he
gives a lot for ya you see this amazing
stuff yeah and you know for you guys for
you know for a lot of people it's not
about anything other than giving back
and being a helping hand because that's
really the [ __ ] richness of life man
that's the essence of what we're all
here for I think is it an addiction
Utley make an excuse for it maybe you
think it's an addiction for you I think
it was an addiction for people to be
generous to be um charitable yeah I
think it blows people mind the response
to gifts and giving people stuff
aniyah's can't stop yeah yeah baby I'm
sure it does blow people's minds
yeah you know you realize wow I get a
lot out of giving you know you think of
Turkey that and you see people you kiss
your hand thing yeah whoa you freaked
out a little bit you want you won um
you know people's life like myself I
want fame on my time and I mean I one
thing when I wanna go and I don't want
anyone you want to give it to me one's
the right time to get it that's the self
is to me I wanted when I'm posting
everything's right and everything's good
I don't what and when I'm you know I'm
down and out and I got it helps it's
weird right
then I love about myself that's going
back to the thing life is gonna live you
yeah you know and you just have to be
ready for the ride [ __ ]
sometimes you think your life is over
this I'm ready to throw the time ready
to dive in [ __ ] what happened no Tyler
never give up never thought I would just
die your ass Perez keep trying and never
give up keep sucking yeah
all right well we wrap this thing let's
do this so where can we find you need
more questions the world is looking at
your marina rock star yes Trina rock
star are you and kick daddy's still
friend to your fight a lot of no we
fought we okay that's all that we fought
this one time on the reunion which I
hate it because I don't like to fight in
public we've been fighting for 20 years
private and trick is crazy everybody
knows that but that's still my brother
we had a long conversation we patched up
we fixed he apologized because he know
he was wrong and a lot of stuff that he
said was was edited out so you didn't
see why I was so mad but he he don't
mean no harm is just he's one of them
dudes that's just he just got a mouth
and he just say he was like how you said
you would be 20 years ago if this was a
show it would be that's just his mouth
so I'll be trying to tell him you're not
20 years ago bro grow up into a
different face
well it's tough to grow up growing up is
hard attacked its energy the chair is
attached to you you think you want to
let you go let you grow up you have let
you go go I go with the ego you let you
go I did all this [ __ ] for you made you
a rapping son you want to get rid of me
you selfish [ __ ] who do you
think
I did all this for you now you want to
get rid of me that's for the same thing
I did all this
then you sit down Mike for [ __ ] now
and I hate got you ready to get rid of
me oh you got you should never talk to
these [ __ ] again I never did
that way but now that you said it that
way that's true so how do I grow up now
I gotta go but gotta be responsible for
my children now I gotta get up at a
certain to make sure he goes to this
baseball camp
alright I'm used to this lounging all
day today is mine now I gotta take mine
I gotta go pick him up now I got to go
check on ya and I gotta take my kids to
tennis now make sure I watch it for two
or three hours when I could be watching
YouTube you know and so that this is
part of growing up and that's something
that I dread my whole life taking the
kids to the movie when I don't want to
watch this [ __ ] cartoon or something
you know it's all about me why do I have
to go to this movie I mean I give these
kids education why they [ __ ] with me
making me take him to the movie I gave
them all this [ __ ] they want me to take
you to the movies to [ __ ] ungrateful
[ __ ] do you think um
like your career when you strike cuz you
remember you say at 13 he was very
scared this little boy doing this whole
thing with you you did so when you
became the biggest figure in the world
right do you think that made you have
ego that bit that's no because my ego
said imma tear this mother [ __ ] does he
think he's better than me uh-huh yeah
and that's show you your mission was
always that you didn't even know my ego
said tear me apart
yeah I'm get too big I started tearing
myself apart destroying my life
destroyed my career doing stupid [ __ ]
yeah okay
it helps you but it doesn't go away yeah
you wanted to give you the everything
all the money and if they buy I don't
need you anymore these days around they
start telling you how piece of [ __ ] you
are you really think you somebody right
you want [ __ ] that I helped you out just
how you treat me you start believing
that to mean that [ __ ] this guy helps
you out I don't know why we have these
guys and I had you know we all have to
things yes whatever make you say we do
that that's sounding yeah yeah you say
to yourself I accomplished all this I
still have to live and if you got these
people fool I know you are you know got
me fooled and I tried so hard to be good
in my mind and [ __ ] if I want to hear
these [ __ ] boys it's interesting
because no one has been there for the
whole ride but you you know from start
to finish
you've never missed a moment of your
life so you know everything yeah
and so that voice is just you yeah you
know it's just an aspect of you why is
that voice there what what is that way
from Jewishness yeah what is what does
that with it why is it just lingering
around just chilling right oh oh no it's
okay challenge test take the fear of the
level you know we all get challenges you
know people on our family might pass
away you mean break up you know and
those are definitely one or two and you
know the number one a tool to kill
yourself over you know it happens every
day a couple of times a day and people
do kill themselves over the loved ones
and stuff you know why did we do that
why did we feel without the existence
had no longer one I exist oh I know what
that feels like right now
yeah yeah so yeah why do you feel that
why me why why do you why why is that a
feeling cuz I'm gonna be honest with you
I there's a feeling a part of me right
this very moment feels that it's because
we put our whole thought pattern on all
our energy into them and we gave our
life and all that thought and all that
power to them yeah but this is the first
thing you love you care about your own
your life you don't care about you want
something no you don't love them you
want to consume them what's them so mean
you want you want to possess them
possess me what but what if it's your
mom you came into this world with this
person no serious still you want to
possess them no one no your mother
doesn't own you you don't own your
mother your mother only responsibility
to make sure you become an adult and you
know you're on your home you may have
feelings for your mother and we love
each other but you're not now the best
of friends have to separate at one time
we all have to be on deal with our
individual life some of us can't live
alone we need people [ __ ] guidance
very hard to live that's why I've been
married three times in my life I'm only
53 because I don't know how to live life
I might kill myself I might get killed I
might kill somebody might go to prison I
came to my life by myself a long single
no my brain is moving too fast
yes I can't I can't I can't stay without
talking you have to touch them buddies
body all the time have to be have to be
high to be drunk [ __ ] no way what what
is that what do you call that don't
that's spirit yeah control you have to
control your spirit I think it experi
wants to kill you
you know put you up to it she want to
kill you but you guys it just wants to
live I don't know what is living
whatever it is beautiful well we're in
that least that we really know bad those
are bad words a beautiful place there's
a bad world some and some cultures
living is dying
you have to die in order to live
yeah but we're so afraid of dying so
we're afraid of living I mean I guess
right why are we afraid of dying because
you don't have to afraid of dealing what
are self-important you love hearing our
voice we love here we don't know that
how do you know oh you know once you
take out there's nothing inside the body
of your body is cremated whether is
going in there what are you gonna hear
we don't know everything we don't know
who we are we don't know nothing about
what if you're really that thing that's
going either by the spirit thing yeah
but if this whole thing is just a shell
is nothing one bizarre they take it out
there's nothing there there's nothing
inside of it when it's cut wide open is
nothing inside but some bags like seize
this off I saw it so therefore I'm
trying to figure out once you're gone
you don't hear everything is black like
when you were born you don't know what
was going on before he was born
maybe you see everything how if your
eyes don't shut clothes you don't see
all right what's your mind your mind is
out of your body though it's gone so
what are you seeing with just a skeleton
and then is your mind nothing not your
brain no it's not your brain there's air
it's nothing is exactly you know it's
yeah because I know it's not that they
can't be I don't see it as a fixture or
nothing tangible I don't I well you know
oxygen people arrive right yeah but you
don't see that you can see oxygen
you can't but how do you know it keeps
your life you could feel this i sir no
no no you can't feel like how you know
you feel oxygen oxygen of the wind it
may be the one you think the winners
oxygen no it's I know oxygen because I
inhaled oxygen before so I know that
it's a different feeling than breathing
natural air well if there wasn't no
trees you know the clouds would be lower
yeah well the clouds yeah they would be
yeah it was no trees yeah why yeah
because the apartment doctor holds the
plan
yeah so cool oxygen yeah I know III
skydive before so I was floating up in
this air that felt weird I didn't know
what the film was gonna be but it it was
a suction so I guess that was oxygen
that was holding me up there so why if
the Eagle the only Eagle that could fly
that high in or the animal can go that
high without suffocating why do I did
why did God choose the ego Eagle get
highs flying burn and it's so heavy why
is he the high fine but you would think
of food that very light would be the
highest line but it's a great question
man I don't know I don't know why are we
doing this why are we doing this no why
did we get to you know live in
civilizations and you know build things
and write books and make movies and make
music and why did we get to do that I
don't know what is the life of a bug or
an ant
maybe it's beautiful what is it like
when we come next and do another one
when I I come next to some anthem
sitting the oil pan you start moving
faster the whole colony they all start
moving faster moving faster and it
stopped moving
yeah I wonder what their profession what
do they call us I saw a coyote of death
I wonder what did he call me when I like
him coyotes are amazing yes I wonder
what he saw me am i washing to him what
am i whether his identity what if this
relationship to me when he see me what
did he say what does he think
well humans have killed a lot of coyotes
so he probably heard you as a predator
and know someone to be afraid of
stay away from take that you know man
this is good stuff man you know get
married yeah yeah how do you see your
life married
I would hope it's good great yeah you
think about you know actually I mean as
different obvious I think the roughly
life um with this individual this is to
the death to while you've been married
before
well to death to us apart we in this
person we're gonna make this work if
he's out there [ __ ] a loudmouth but
we're gonna make this work we could this
is what no this is it's our obligation
to God though oh yeah but the obligation
is to me I have never before because
this is the reason I just believed in
you know I just wanted to say okay if I
get married I want it to be for
everybody and I mean hey son like you
said you've been married three times so
it's not a right or wrong I don't know
the issues but people I've known her
that's been married 40 years of 16 years
and I've access woman after being
married for 16 years like what happened
which on your husband's you did like it
wasn't a bad thing
no we just she said um they grew apart
and I'm like what does that mean growing
apart like this like y'all still friends
you have a kid so y'all have a mutual
you know thing but you grew apart
growing apart from somebody that you've
in the same house went for what did you
grow apart from the way he looked that
he grow apart from the way you look like
what was it a physical thing I don't
really understand what's going apart me
and she was like no we just we just grew
apart and I was like but then now are
you prepared to start over she was like
absolutely because after being with the
same person for 16 years of your life
had a child you're Mary and you're gonna
start over well when you think of the 16
years be [ __ ] I'm glad to get out of
this stuff that was the point and you're
gonna get the bushes big [ __ ] yeah I'm
happy to get out of this stuff because
that was the case you won't get divorce
you know they have to really be bad in
order to get divorce you know I'm saying
like if I'm like beating my wife facias
they should leave me like that you know
I mean but the perception like say this
is some good or worse you know when you
hit after you know when I'm young yeah
where I'm like that's my you got a
hundred [ __ ] I got money and stuff
and I go to this really painful spill
you got the egos really painful the
Eagle said she left you yep I know but
that's why I haven't got married
because of those reasons and I know is a
part of me there's a very little
immature part no I got to check this out
you know once you say I do [ __ ] change
bow once you say I do
why is your girlfriend your fancy for so
long and everything's great and we had
different weddings great but since you
said I'd do something changing just
don't know what it is right something
changed yes on the way the Sun changing
you say I do yeah good energy but it's
energy different it's a call to UM to
serve yeah this is a responsibility I
got to make sure I make a Lisa angry as
possible yeah so okay that's fine almost
that becomes my life you ever had a man
that you with in total like Jesus
absolute thought just the thought of you
yes well then that's definitely I guess
he feels about you that how does that
feel I don't want my ego to kick in but
um see that's the thing with me you know
what people always say this stuff these
things to me in and people always say
your ego isn't big enough because I done
me down a lot I don't really I don't
really be like okay my chest is up yeah
I feel like that I'd be like okay thank
you
it's one of those things I don't know
but a lot of people be like you just
don't beef up your ego to know they
don't know what they're talking about
your ego don't leave you alone keep
everybody away from you know if I had
ego I can be with my parent my wife and
my kids my hope everybody I've done this
three times they left the house and left
me the house alone the kids everybody
left me my ego who I am I'm running [ __ ]
you know this is my [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm the
[ __ ] I did this and that and
this and that and this and that yo yo a
bunch of hi I'm [ __ ] them well you
caught good good luck come come Club
[ __ ] you know I mean when I
heard these kill children's feelings and
stuff and these are my children I
remember mm feeling because I'm trying
to make them tough with no regard for
their feeling
to something and then they all leave and
you don't have anybody to be badass in
front no and then being alone you find
out how stupid you are
yeah me alone you're stupid oh [ __ ] you
start calling them and saying once a
sorry we offer them some money than I
picking up the phone good that's all
that happens you know I don't sit down
and talk them and explain why I was
wrong
hating me for money but you name the car
what you got baby I love you you know I
mean that doesn't work for a while but
then they really start playing yeah I
need this they don't care about you yes
call you and they need something I had
to change all that around you know Oh F
sorry I didn't know how it was gonna
work
how long we make these kids like me they
see me disrespectful to their mother
they see me either
they had other brothers and sisters
while I was married to their mother so
what I yeah yeah almost let's do a
[ __ ] rivals card yeah but do you
think that come from your career no come
from my insecurities come from my shame
and my guilt
yeah as we like just in life overall
yeah so what part of that do you
separate from like the superior or do
you what part of that do you separate
from like the superior life your
superior like movies even I stay far
away from that as possible I'm your
superior life yeah that's what I think
it's superior you know what or what
everybody else needs the perception of
what people think that's interesting
people perception of me my perceptions
my perception of their thumb was it was
made out of fear so they really don't
know who I am
that was just a fear-based perception of
what I wanted people to think of me you
know that's just how it is when you're
afraid and you only know growing up that
people respect fear you respectfully
that those bullies that you in fear I
thought you know and when you don't have
enough lovely itself you act out in that
way
mean and disrespectful to people you
know not I love yourself just very calm
how do you learn to love yourself when
you're young in this business and it's
all about ego sometimes you have itself
how do you explain self love love self
love to me means I'm going out with a
couple of girls [ __ ] a couple of
girls buying some great clothes that
stuff love to me you know all do
yourself love to me so I have the fan of
self love is just taking care treating
yourself night yeah
nice whole first date like pamper
yourself inner peace just relaxed and
chillin nobody like I don't know
meditating I think yeah younger you just
your ego is really big but see the
difference and what I say when you say
how you said growing up is hard because
20 years ago versus 20 years now and in
the knowledge and just how the stuff
that you say is so needed for a lot of
people I believe well and just because
the industry that I live in just a lot
of people don't truly know who
themselves are they don't even
understand and they don't even really
these conversations will never come by
because sometimes two people can't even
sit in a room and have a conversation
that's about the same thing but
different you you're 20 years past
versus you're 20 years now is a whole
different level of like light of
maturity like when I say friends like a
tree for him right now if like if he was
here but for him like what I be trying
to explain to him is that this why be
trying to get him to be not like what to
say like when I mean like you've done a
great job your career your legacy so
when I say grow up or grow to this face
I don't think he's just to do you just
treat from the hood now you ain't grown
up I'm just gonna always be there [ __ ]
that's just who I am you know what I
mean and me I love him so much like I
feel like I've grown in the space I want
him to grow like he'd been married I
didn't so you know I just think
different levels of people how you have
to get to a certain phase and understand
your flaws Fox all the stuff that you've
done to be able to be to say it like
no you know no one having my experience
you know with myself and people who I've
been around then it's tough dealing with
reality that probably that we like I
said if we're gonna die and we live it
we don't think about and then we get
close to and then well now we have to
think about we all we avoid thinking
about all this time the poem that the
object time come do we have to think
about it and then face face nothing that
fast a healthy I don't get shot on hit
by a car don't get a disease and I say I
got 20 years left what am I gonna do
some is 20 years old people yeah how do
I do that without helping myself yeah
yeah you know I mean three what do you
do what do you do for this twenty you
and I think about and I could sue myself
with dying what do I think about this
meditate about what dying clearing your
mind how do you clear your mind listen
to your breathing listen to the sounds
around you stop thinking you know every
morning I said I'd do 30 minutes of
meditation and I [ __ ] all I do is I
sit down and I start listening to my
breathing going in and out of my nose
and every time I thought comes into my
head I just let it go and I come back to
my breathing every time and they do that
over and over again every day for the
last four years and man [ __ ] starts to
just slow the [ __ ] down stop thinking so
much searches feeling [ __ ] you know and
that's really scary yeah my over-thinker
it gets scared what people are yeah and
then you come out you know you come out
the other side near [ __ ] and you know
what to do because we all have something
that the universe is putting us on a
path to do for just riding that wave man
riding it right to the [ __ ] end you
know whatever that is pretty eternity
not a good wave now though it's a great
way this is a great wave it's an awesome
wave no but yeah
I mean that's how I do it meditate man
you can meditate for 20 years Mike I
think you'd be down dude you're already
on it you're already doing it I don't
want to miss anything
well meditating helps you not miss
anything
because you're just in everything well
hey man let's get out of here
yeah I'm hungry Treena thank you so much
it's so much fun I learned so much and a
lot of deep conversation yeah great
stuff I like to learn from everything I
do I learn so do you hang out boyfriend
you come to shows women hang guy we go
everywhere we just live in this world
y'all here living in life terms listen
to that everybody just get out there and
start living y'all yeah hey and thanks
for watching and listening to this
episode this is one of my favorite
[ __ ] friends until next time be sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel hot
box of Mike Tyson yeah I'm Evan Brittain
I might die 10 I'm Trina and that's
Trina everybody thank you so much until
next time we are out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]